hey guys merry here at PAX Prime 2015
and today we are showing the latest and
greatest indie game that we could find
all around packs and I am here with eat
I for you are from untamed okay and
today you're gonna show a game that I've
actually seen last year but your back
because you guys are actually about to
release its mushroom 11 yeah we're
coming out very soon a couple months and
yeah we're very excited to be back on to
India mega booth oh so cool so let's
actually get right into it and show off
your game this is such a unique concept
that I've never actually seen before
because you you are this is strange and
amorphous goo but the idea that you're
actually erasing your being in order to
progress in the story that's right the
only force you have really is but you
can only remove cells but it always
maintains its size you can if you you
can split yourself or your trim or you
know mold yourself into any shape but
you'll always maintain the same number
of cells across across the screen if
something you know falls into lava or
whatever it will immediately regrow
someplace else it's great and you know
you said lava because you can actually
die in this it looks it looks like a
nice simple casual puzzle puzzle game
and it is like it is calming but in the
same sense you actually you can die in
you can and I am it happens a lot
further down yeah you will die did you
have to dial up and and a lot of the lot
of you these elements are like kind of
benign like you know just clamp onto
things and apply some force and then
they fall down or or another puzzle
would be like like in this case you have
to split yourself in order to you know
in this case push the button the other
one goes through the door see but it
gets more interesting and complicated
later on where i'll show you how you die
if you if you there's like this huge gap
here you don't know what to do you would
be like okay I'm
try here oh you're going to huh but you
realize that there's one wave could
actually cross over this lot of damage
is to use the fact that you can trim it
to in any shape and I can squeeze in
this thing which holds you right exactly
now it goes with the piece of you that's
larger or because if you split yourself
into two and half of you die that's a
great question in fact that usually what
it does try to kind of like average it
figure out where you really mean to be
and in this case it was very clear you
want to go into this save point so you
would kind of realize that the other
pieces are not exactly where you're
aiming to be so this is another little
puzzle that just teaches you the fact
that you have in some sort of form I
want to show a couple more interesting
interesting things let me just see like
it's not just about you know shape it's
there are some elements that are more
like skill base one of my favorite is
like the following buildings usually
players when they see this is there to
get a little
it's really nice to see players be like
you know they don't understand this
actually it's not oh but once you go
through this you understand really that
this much Mac and allows you to compose
really fast as well not just you know
meticulously there are a lot of things
that you can do it yeah you're changing
it up a lot on players from either
environmental puzzles where you have to
change something in the environment or
you're learning something new about your
actual form and the physics behind it
but then you even go as far as there's
there's actual boss fights in this game
that's right you start increasing the
challenges incrementally as the player
progressive that's that's right end and
you were saying you were talking about
the different elements and it's true you
actually never change across this game
but the environment changes all the time
and and teaches you new things that that
you can do with this kind of control
over this character in this case for
example this this is the first time you
need to kind of conform conform to
something that is unstable you know it's
really hard to control this thing but if
you shift your mass properly
then you know you figure out how to move
you become you say you become one to the
mushroom you see the mushroom you are
the less you are you are the much you
know right now what's your goal to
attack this boss so in this case and in
up in many other cases the bosses are
really not there to hurt you they're
just they're you know they're more of an
obstruction and you got to find a way to
get around it or through it exactly and
in this case you just need to destroy
those seeds which is generally the goal
behind the game like destroy all these
mutations angriest flower I've ever seen
yes don't want to know my my my sources
of inspiration from first some of these
that's I we've got about my fun parts
like figuring out what I would like to
see and just go with it because you know
why not you know that's why we're
developers to put in or are you know
fears and and and inspiration you see
there's a lot of you in this game
there's this I put everything I I fear
and everything I analyze your team it's
so the game is my design and well I also
did the programming and they wrote a
story Simon kono is the guy behind the
amazing art and another thing and also
my wife is also a designer and an artist
she's also helping a lot with the game
and Simon's wife is the producers it's
basically two married couples so you
can't really get more indie than that
that's what you're doing right now is
you're picking yourself up and using
your mass to weigh down areas exact
address exactly something we have to
mention with this game is just how
beautiful it is despite the fact that
you've worked very hard to make
everything ugly you've tried really hard
to make destructed environments that are
destroying like they're just dilapidated
worlds but they're still so beautiful
what was the inspiration behind creating
environments that were destroyed so
oh so actually it's exactly that Simon I
think we we used to call it the like a
happy death environment like this is uh
oh happy day I don't know good name but
anyway idea that you keep expecting in
this game and other games as well to
figure out where the people are I mean
you are this organism obviously there's
there's summat hence to to humanity
being there at some point and you keep
wanting to find those people and you you
won't really and there's something about
this tipping the scales here hold up
sorry and no just you we have this
understanding that you know we it's all
about us and I kind of wanted to make a
game that you kind of understand that we
are we're not gonna be here for long
okay especially in this yeah it looks
very post-apocalyptic world you have
that you've created here new year you're
starting to add more elements now
there's like blue bugs and purple goo
yeah it was like acid I'm running
through it it kind of like just want to
show and it's just uh just a little bit
of the things that you can do with it
it's stunning actually I was shown this
game originally last year Alexander
Bruce was stopping people in the entire
area saying stop and look at this game
you've never seen anything like it and
he was right I've never seen anything
like this it's it's probably one of the
most interesting games I've never even
seen this puzzle you're starting to show
me stuff I haven't I'm sorry just like I
sometimes enjoy just playing that's the
one thing I like when I show it to other
people there's some sense when not a lot
of things are chasing you there is some
sense of tranquility and just playing
with this thing so which is I enjoy yeah
it's beautiful and and you do not have a
really state yet what it's coming soon
it's coming soon around October and
we're going to announce it very soon and
super nervous and excited that's the
best feeling though thank you so much
for showing me your game eat I thank you
thank you guys and thanks for watching
you guys that was mushroom 11 coming out
very soon and for the latest game
coverage don't be going anywhere else
stay tuned to gamespot com see you guys
you